you have probably heard that Vladimir
Putin is worth over 200 billion dollars
and when you consider his 20 palaces
villas and residences his impressive
stock portfolio and his luxury yachts
and planes you see at this number is not
ludicrous in 2014 the CIA confirmed that
Putin controlled assets worth 40 billion
dollars in 2007 12 years ago so even if
the figure isn't that high by now there
is no doubt that Putin is worth tens of
billions of dollars make him want to
richest people in the world but how
exactly did he get so much money without
getting caught well here's a top three
ways that Putin makes money and make
sure stick around till the end to fire
the top three ways that he keeps his
vast fortune hidden starting off we have
failed promises when he was deputy mayor
of st. Petersburg the city was hit with
a massive food shortage in order to
raise some money a program was
established in which raw materials will
be sold internationally and the profits
be used to buy more food Putin was a
foreigner in this program and assured
the public that they would receive tons
of food
he literally promised that they would
get 2,000 tons of butter and milk
whether food actually came or not is
unclear but what was revealed by an
investigation led by city councilor
marina was that there was a 124 million
dollar disparity of course Putin denied
all charges and blamed other city
leaders for the disparity if that's not
convincing enough here's another example
Putin had registered an economic
relations committee called xx trust the
government gave the company a 2.5
billion Bubo or about 39 million dollar
construction project but as you probably
already guessed construction never
started there are many accounts of such
promises that fell through making this
seem like a prominent way that Putin
pulled in his initial wealth but clearly
continuously cheating the public cannot
go unnoticed and is quite risky so
naturally he would quickly move away
from such tactics move into investing
and his favorite place invest was all
businesses as he has giant stakes in
many oil companies the US Treasury has
revealed that they have evidence to
typoon the profits from businessmen on
US sanctions list Kennedy timchenko this
man is not only a longtime friend of
Putin but also co-owner of all giant
Gunvor which trades almost 3% the
world's oil is likely that Putin has
invest
a lot of money into this company and
fostered its growth but this cannot be
confirmed the US government has however
confirmed that Putin has several secret
investments in the energy sector he also
doesn't just use a corrupt money
investments
he often invest using his power for
instance max fredison who's one of
hundreds of exiled businessmen told the
BBC that Putin gave him the monopoly to
provide all to an airport in the 90s in
exchange for a secret four percent stake
in his business so okay
he was power and money to make a couple
of investments here and there but how
profitable could these ventures really
be the answer is unimaginably lucrative
Russia didn't have much experts on the
Soviet regime by Africa lapse from 1993
to 2015 brush export around 10 percent
more eager than imported it is estimated
that over the past two decades
Russia has socked away investments
abroad are equal to about 230 percent of
the gross national income and that's not
even including any gains on those
investments economists estimate that
currently these investments only account
for 26 percent of national income so
what happened to the other over two
hundred percent considering that the
Russian gross national income is
equivalent to four hundred and seventy
two billion dollars two hundred percent
is equal to almost one hundred trillion
dollars clearly these investments have
proven very fruitful and you can bet
that Putin pockets a lot of this money
finally the third major way Putin
accumulated his wealth is by helping
countries bypass sanctions Putin has
notoriously helped many countries
circumvent US sanctions with the most
recent being Iran by denying their
runyan government the ability to trade
and access the international currency
market it was hoped that this would
increase economic and social pressure
which could help be mobilize the Islamic
Revolution Guards corpse who aim to
preserve strict Islamic rule over the
country with Russia helping Iran bypass
these sanctions Russia is able to park a
nice sum of money as goods are no dust
all our premium to Iran and it's not
deserve on either
Hera's kim jungeun get his mercies
motorcades whenever he's visiting other
countries there are international
sanctions on North Korea so there is no
way that he is getting it legally when
researchers dove into the topic they
were able to discover that came from a
Russian ship owned by a wealthy Russian
man now whether Putin was involved in
this is unclear however I doubt a rich
businessman would take on this great
risk without political support as a risk
would simply not be worth did to him
especially considering our riches there
are plenty of other Russian
organizations that have been found to
have ties with North Korea as well like
the Russian financial society this was
opened in 2003 and had just one office
it mainly provided out payment services
for small businesses and individuals but
as of December 2018 the entity had less
than $600,000 in capital and less than 6
million assets which is notoriously low
for a financial institution this first
concerns as the institution seemed to be
more like a buffer account used to
transfer money rather than legitimate
business but as a US Treasury Department
went deeper into an investigation the
institution's website completely went
down this is thought to be the latest
discovery of Russia popping North Korea
by pass sanctions despite this being
taken down there are definitely many
more institutions involved in such shady
business as such keys are constantly
surfacing for example just a couple of
months before this in August the US
sanctioned a grocer used Commercial Bank
for carrying out transactions on behalf
of Han Jung soo the chief representative
the foreign trade Bank of North Korea so
there are plenty more schemes to uncover
but in the meantime Putin is PI and
making a good sum from his activities in
essence while it cannot be confirmed he
was expected that Putin made his fortune
by under delivering on his promises and
then putting that capital into lucrative
investments all while adding other
countries bypassed international
sanctions so nothing too crazy but how
is he able to cover all of his
footprints leaving no evidence at all
first of all he takes advantage of shell
companies a shell company is simply a
corporation with financial assets but no
significant business activity there have
been several reports suggesting that
money that he makes are funneled into
such shell companies usually
funds originate from Russia passing
through tsipras onto British Virgin
Islands and the Cayman Islands in each
step of the way several layers of
anonymous shell companies are used to
make it difficult to identify the true
owner finally after passing through 20
to 30 of these companies the money
arrives in the u.s. often a wilmington
delaware or the UK these countries are
chosen as they have
most fearful loss for this type of
activity in fact the US Treasury
estimates that in 2015 there was 300
billion dollars being laundered in the
u.s. so that is how Putin's April's
tourist vast fortune across the globe
without getting caught
but the only issue here is that would be
very tough for him to use the money
without getting caught one of the
tactics he uses to get around this is
receiving gifts he most likely transfers
money to companies and then takes the
products he wants ask gifts
this makes the company look good that
they are often giving away very
expensive products and this service is a
good excuse were put to use such
products without raising suspicion for
example in the past from an album avec
the Chelsea Football Club owner
apparently gifted at 57 meter 35 million
dollar yacht to mr. Putin now vollum is
Abramovich's is worth 12 point 1 billion
dollars which is obviously a huge feat
35 million dollars dollars huge amount
especially when you consider that most
his wealth is probably not in liquid
form plus I suspect that people with
about ten times more wealth than him
like Jeff Bezos or Bill Gates wouldn't
gift at 35 million dollar yacht to the
president of their home country for
instance you think Elon Musk Whitgift a
yacht sir president of South Africa
finally Putin uses his friends and
failed me to spread the money out such
is the case with Russian musician Sergey
roldugin
who is quite possibly Putin's best
friend Sergey is a lifeline musician who
has travelled around the world playing
for many important people today he's a
head of music house in Saint Petersburg
now that's all good
but you wouldn't expect him to be a
businessman in fact he's even said that
he wasn't much of a businessman despite
this the information revealed and Panama
Papers would suggest otherwise the
documents indicate that he is the owner
of several companies and the documents
even contain his signature or what is
supposed to be a signature as they could
very well be forged the papers also
unveiled that 2 billion US dollars
flowed through his companies that word
uses some sort of offshore Network while
he was a popular musician it is clear
that this type of money could not be
made through his legitimate career
furthermore his companies didn't retain
much money they were just stops in an
intricate network of fake businesses it
seems like Sergey was just a pawn a
network and many a Putin's family
members play much more significant role
his closest family members not only hold
the bulk of his wealth but also help him
spend it for instance Putin may get
uncle to use the money to buy a giant
mansion under his name Putin as well as
his uncle when Putin isn't there can
enjoy living in this new palace there's
obviously a lot of legal nuances with
that but that is essentially what is
taking place so Putin is April historian
uses money by using shell companies
gifts as well as a friends and family
but all of this is just a waste I've
surfaced there may very well be
undiscovered pathways used to move
billions more but here's the thing when
we have so much information about
amazing uses money why has he not been
convicted well the obvious answer is
that there is simply not enough concrete
evidence and moreover Putin is in power
right now and it wouldn't be a wise
decision to go against him as you may
very well find yourself dead given all
of this what do Russians think about
Putin well they have a very broad range
of opinions on this matter some are
outraged that prison is so wealthy using
state money when a job in an office for
50000 rubles or a hundred a month is the
best one can hope for others have simply
given up saying that doesn't matter I
wouldn't have voted anyways this is an
election with no choice at the same time
there are also people who don't mind
Putin as their lives are running
smoothly and couldn't care less about
the corruption going on at the top
Putin is totally not supposed to be able
to fire in 2020 for election and he may
stop running altogether after his
current term but despite this he will no
doubt retain power influence in the
government even if he has not presidents
so he'll probably not even be convicted
even after his presidency so what do you
guys think about all of this do you guys
think Putin is a cold-blooded scammer or
just a nice man wanting to improve
Russia make sure to comment that down
below also if you guys liked this video
dimension drop a like and consider
subscribing if I see more videos just
like this one but until then I'm hari
now see you guys on the next one
[Music]